[Applause]
here we go again it's the mid-month PS
Plus update which adds more games to the
extra and premium tiers of PlayStation
Plus the Christmas update adds a total
of 22 games which can be played from
Tuesday the 20th of December we have a
lot to get through so let's crack on
first up is the grab Fest that is WWE
2k22 after a year off from the annual
series it has returned with a complete
redesign to the gameplay engine and
control scheme create your own Superstar
and climb the Dizzy Heights all the way
to headline WrestleMania building
friendships and alliances along the way
which could break down at any moment
there's a story to play through both
male and female versions as you decide
your direction in interviews and your
prowess in the ring or maybe failures
change the story's direction there's a
general manager mode for Fantasy Bookers
out there who want to show the WWE how
to plan compelling storylines and the
Showcase mode is here to relive iconic
past events from WWE history if you've
always thought about trying a wrestling
game but never actually done it this is
a good chance for you how about an open
world first person shooter from the
world of Far Cry while well there's
three of them in fact first we visit
Hope County USA in Far Cry 5. we are
tasked with dethroning a preacher who
has risen to prominence yet the day we
are sent to arrest him becomes the day
the Doomsday cult has foreseen Joseph
seeds followers and family members
inhabit different areas of Hope County
and we must go through them to stop
seeds plan expect set-piece action
scenes with epic gunfights or you could
play stealthy and go unnoticed who am I
kidding nobody plays Far Cry to be
stealthy we must build up a resistance
to face seed and his Fanatics allowing a
buddy system to be used such as asking a
sniper to cover you from distance or
calling in a dog who'll fight alongside
you Co-op is available too I do
recommend playing Far Cry 5 in Co-op
it's great should you complete Far Cry 5
story then you should jump into Far Cry
New Dawn 17 years after the apocalyptic
events foreseen by Joseph seed the world
has changed Nature has taken back the US
and new villains are in charge large
twins Lou and Mickey are the antagonists
and their band of Highwaymen New Dawn
introduces a weapon crafting system as
the modern world is thrown back to the
Dark Ages but wait there's more Far Cry
Primal is also here taking the series
all the way back to the Stone Age we
play as a seasoned hunter-gatherer born
to survive in this unforgiving world but
there's no vehicles here so we have to
use saber-toothed tigers and bears
instead of course Primal is built on Far
Cry 4's engine not Far Cry 5 so it
doesn't feel as refined and responsive
as the other titles added today but it
does boast the highest average score of
all three which is just less than 8 out
of 10. next we can't have a PS plus
extra update without a Yakuza game well
there's three technically this time
first Yakuza like a dragon and don't
worry if you're having a bout of deja vu
right now like a dragon was on PS plus
essential only four months ago and the
defining difference between this and
most other Yakuza games is the fighting
system it's turn based this allows the
depth of options to shine through as you
beat someone round the Hedge with a snow
leopard or a bowl of fruit the options
in this game are strange the whole setup
is coming out of prison 18 years after
you were sent down and must reintegrate
with your Yakuza Underworld the second
Yakuza game this month is the Yakuza 6
the song of life touted as the final
installment of Kazuma kiru's story The
Fighting system in here is fully free no
turn-based action here and actually it's
been simplified so much it's far easier
to pick up and play than ever before the
story is about kiryu's last criminal
case to seek out a hit and run driver
who took the life of a family member as
that unwinds everything links back to
previous games and the Japanese Clans
and underworld Yakuza bosses in the
shadows if that's too sad for you don't
worry there's a cat cafe and you can
sing karaoke whenever you like finally
take a look at judgment a spin-off from
the Yakuza series we play as takayuki
Yagami a private investigator who is
desperate to clear his name the plot
revolves around a series of murders and
you are the only one who can find and
stop the culprit the psychological
Thriller storyline has been plotted by
many especially after the super silly
things that can happen in typical Yakuza
games will you try this one next we have
both Middle Earth games shadow of war
and Shadow of Mordor the best way to
describe these games is as Assassin's
Creed setting the Lord of the Rings
world the most amazing element in this
franchise is the Nemesis system that
generates your foes randomly as each are
faced your relationship with them
changes they may be fearful of your
Legend they may have heard about your
weaknesses and change the way they fight
since the last time you met this makes
replaying the game so much fun as those
enemies will most certainly be different
next time with new personalities and new
dialogue to discover chatting with
Gollum while keeping away from the Gaze
of Lord Sauron may not be completely in
keeping with the books but it's a good
time all the same how about an RPG that
is heavily inspired by the famous blood
bloodborne and Dark Souls franchises
mortal shell feels like an expansion to
those worlds with the same Aesthetics
and obtuse storytelling and shamelessly
runs with it battles are tense and
require timing to succeed or you'll get
used to seeing the fail screen many many
times if you like Trials of Will and
High Learning curves mortal shell may be
a good choice if you don't like
soulsborne games run away run away while
you can another RPG which couldn't be
more different is Adventure Time pirates
Jake and Finn travel the world in their
boat and take part in turn-based fights
the usual roles exist with tank support
and DPS and you must learn the best
combination to win the voice actors are
here from the TV show making the world
of Adventure Time more compelling and
Jake will even turn into different
vehicles to help speed up exploration
pillars of a 10 Unity II dead fire
completes the RPGs for the month and
this is more of a point-and-click
isometric RPG the themes are quite dark
we play as the Watcher a person who can
see into the souls of others lovely how
about a puzzle game check out The
Pedestrian we play as a stick drawing
tasked with moving from one street sign
to another the core mechanic is building
a level yourself and then running
through it your ability to put things in
the right place dictates how easy or
impossible the platforming element will
be the complexity builds up but it's
definitely manageable and you'll have it
done within five hours another puzzle
game this month is Evil Genius 2 world
domination imagine if you were grew in
Despicable Me and your minions would
complete tasks following your
instructions essentially Evil Genius 2
plays like a Sim game something like two
point campus just nothing near as good
next The Escapist 2 is an escape
simulator as we are locked up in prison
and we want to get out each day is
defined by routine picking times and
opportunities to find a way to escape is
your only interest from searching cells
while guards are looking the wrong way
to digging holes to Freedom get caught
and that hole will be filled back in and
you'll be back to square one worms wmd
is a turn-based war simulator but with
worms everything is set on a flat 2D
plane and each worm waits for their time
to have 30 seconds to either fight or
flee with countless power-ups it's a
total blast with friends the kids games
this month are Ben 10 Power Trip in
which we control Ben and his Legion of
incredible aliens solving puzzles
collecting power-ups and defeating
anything that stands in your way and
gigantosaurus the game a tie into the
Disney TV show Pat platformer part racer
and now for those people who have
PlayStation Plus premium here we are
games for December 2022 Ridge Racer 2 on
the PSP is the Highlight the iconic
racer will be up Res to Modern standards
and they've added a quick save and
Rewind feature for ease of use my
personal favorite game this month is
Heavenly sword the PS3 game that tells
the story of naraco as she embarks on a
quest of Vengeance against attacking
forces Oddworld Abe's Exodus is the PS1
title this month we have the Modern Day
remake last month so now it's time to
try the original and look there's one
more pinball Heroes on the PSP so that's
your month 22 games please let me know
your thoughts it's been a pleasure I'm
Adam see ya